Hey! Ernest.
Hey!
We were at the front together in France.
Of course.
- Good to see you.
- Good to see you, too.
Woo!
Do you want to try another version?
Which is...
I want to...
Let's go to that other take,
the previous take, because that was perfect and-
Can we go to take two when they come right through the car.
See that played is him-
Somehow the camera was in the right-
Yeah, maybe.
Maybe it was that we got to our mark
a little sooner this time.
We can get there a beat later.
- So you see his hands between the seats.
- Yeah.
And if I put my hand up higher that will help too, right?
I think it will. It’s really...
We get the idea,
but we don't. It doesn't register.
He doesn’t register that she's not taking it.
She's not registering.
- But in the previous take, the one I just showed you he did.
-  Yeah.
- Yeah, yeah.
- She did register.
But I also think it’s- it’s the combination of us making little.
Right, right. Okay well.
That was pretty good.
There. That’s good.
That's good.
That's really good.
Now when Kelsey comes in...
Can we run that back just a little?
I wanna see...
Run that back a little bit.
Back, back, back. Right before Kelsie comes over.
When you- when you do, “Hey I got money on this!”
- It’s really, “Oh! I got money on this.” Really-
- Ok.
- Go after it, go after it.
Because it just becomes, “Hey I got money on this.”
Ok.
Good.
I'm trying to ignore her,
but I might be f*cking up my own timing.
So I should just be staring straight at her
and then a beat when she arrives.
Yeah.
- And she's in the clear and then I go.
- Right.
- Not looking for her ride.
So if you find her that could also work.
Because yeah.
And when you get-
you have to rearrange the races
or just
just until “Nice seeing you”
and we’ll stay wide
and then she gets in the car, Kelsey comes over
and then the races start.
Yeah it would still be the same thing, it would be me like
where Kathy is we would be hanging out
And him coming across the street alone.
It would be like walking up to a cab, right?
- Just like walking casual
- Yeah.
Okay so let's, let's do the other one first
and you’ll get use to what's going on
and then do a slightly different version.
- Yeah.
- That’s great
So, so many guys who were sitting outside all the time,
- you know?
- Yeah.
- You want us to sit, right?
- Oh yeah, yeah, yeah.
Just hanging out, you know?
In front of the General Store...
watching the day go by.
Just enjoying the day?
Enjoy the day.
You still have me on a pretty long lens but I guess that’s ok?
- I think it’s alright.
- Yeah.
Because it would be nice to get...
Yeah, ok.
Full figure.
Very good.
- We’ll take a few minutes.
- Alright.
[in English]
Ma'am, you need a ride?
That's my bucket, right there.
Thank you.
[horn honks]
Gotta be careful.
A lot of characters
around here today.
[whistles]
[Kelsie] Hey, Ernest!
Hey, Kelsie Morrison! [laughs]
We were at the front
together in France.Hey!
How you doing?
Great to see you!
You too. You too.
My wife, Catherine Cole.
Oh, pleased to meet you.
Pleased to meet you.
Full blood.
Sky People, right? Sky People?
-Middle Water. Middle Water.
-[Ernest] Oh.
-[car engine roars]
-Lot of money on this.
[whistles]
[horse whinnies]
Whoo!
You got money on this race?
No. No.
Let's go, then.
Yep.
[bystanders whooping, clamoring]